good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the 52nd season at Theatre 80
the seventh year for the Museum of
American Gangster
welcome to the c-span audience I am
extraordinarily happy to have Deirdre
here to speak about this book it is one
of my great interests growing up in
organized crime I was raised in the
religious Society of Friends when
anybody ever says oh you know I don't
subscribe to organized religion I always
say I don't either I grew up Quaker
where organized crime the only thing we
ever did in an organized way we don't
have theology or so is break the law
from the 1600s when we came about till
now with draft resistance the
Underground Railroad the sanctuary
movement the only thing we do in an
organized way is break the law and so in
our museum we began to redefine the way
people look at organized crime as a
struggle between American moral
certainty the thou shalt not rules and
the enculturation to Liberty where
people say yes but it's our right to an
organized crime has always come out of
that intersection between these two
great concepts that are always at war
and define us and one of the great great
characters in this story one of the true
geniuses come out of this is Al Capone
and it is so wonderful to have a new
book that really delves into him as
something more than the stereotypes and
cartoon figures that you see on TV and
so enough from me other than a little
housekeeping if anything horrible
happens the emergency exits are here and
here if you have anything that will make
noise during the talk
cell phones beepers small children dates
from New Jersey please do turn them off
now also
please there do not take any film or
recordings of the talk in progress very
important without further adieu and
great joy Deirdre a bear right thank you
[Applause]
period afterwards we're going to step up
some ice in an orderly fashion and
actively well thank you all for coming
it's delightful to see everyone here and
so many good friends that makes me
especially happy I'm going to begin
tonight by reading a few pages from the
book it's going to give you a brief
introduction to Al Capone starting with
the man himself and then with the legend
that he became and then I'm going to
talk a little bit about his life and his
legacy had to sort of give you a sense
of what you're going to find when you
read the book yourself this is how I
begin the book this is the story of a
ruthless killer a scofflaw a keeper of
brothels and bordellos a tax cheat a
perpetrator of frauds a convicted felon
and a mindless blubbering idiot this is
also the story of a loving son a husband
and a father who described himself as a
business man whose job was to serve the
people what they wanted Al Capone with
all of these he died in 1947 and almost
seven decades later it seems that
anywhere one travels in the world people
still recognize his name and they have
something to say about who he was and
what he did everyone has an opinion and
yet within the deeply private world of
his extended family there is an ongoing
quest to find definitive answers about
the families most famous member the
saying goes that all family history is
often a mystery and that all families
are
narratives difficult to read from the
outside attempting to reconstruct the
truth of a family is very much like
trying to solve the most complicated
puzzle imaginable and in the case of
those who bear a name that is famous or
as in the case of Al Capone's relatives
and descendants descendants infamous the
task can be heavy indeed some of his
relatives found it easier to change
their surname than to deal with its
history they chose to distance
themselves and deny the relationship for
a number of reasons some merely wanted
to lead ordinary private lives some said
they feared reprisals from gangland
Chicago while still others who remained
connected in varying degrees said they
wanted to make their way in the world
unencumbered by the long shadow of Al
Capone and still there were those who
kept the Capone name but said it was the
reason why they had to lead peripatetic
lives some moving as far away as they
could get while others only moved
cautiously from one town to another
throughout northern Illinois
never far from the security and the
familiar environment of Chicago in
recent years the question of who has the
right to claim a legitimate place within
the family of Al Capone has resulted in
some interesting pieces that may or may
not fit into the puzzle of its history
you who only know him from newspapers
stories will never realize the real man
he is said his sister Mafalda in 1929
when he was in his prime
it's a remark echoed today by his
granddaughter's who have only recently
become involved in sorting out what they
call their amazing family history one of
the questions they ponder repeatedly is
how one man
embody so many different personality
traits they talk among themselves about
their family history and they argue and
they debate about whose memory is the
most correct and which is the closest to
the truth
they strive to assist their grandparents
and parents with honesty objectivity
distance and detachment and they admit
the difficulty if not the impossibility
of arriving at a definitive conclusion
when they talk about their papa as they
call him they first put Al Capone in air
quotes and they asked themselves what
gave rise to the myth into the legend
how did the grandfather they adored fit
into all these stories where was the
real person within the grandiose and
exaggerated public personality whose
exploits continue to grow ever more
outrageous seven decades after his death
it'll be 80 years next year that Al
Capone has been dead what was it that
makes the name of a man who died sick
broke and demented in 1947 so instantly
recognizable a decade and a half into a
brand new century are we fascinated with
him today because of the so called
roaring 20s the colorful time in which
he lived is it because we now seek to
understand the many ethnic histories
that formed our country and therefore
the circumstances of his birth and
family life as an italian-american that
might shed some light on our own
assimilation as Americans or is it
simply Al Capone's larger-than-life
personality the outsized figure who
strutted across our historical stage for
such a brief time that we did not have
enough time when he was with us to
assess him after so many intervening
years
can we figure him out and after seven
decades is nothing left but a myth the
members of his family agree with me that
the Enigma of Al Capone is a riddle to
be solved and now is the time to try to
do it and now I'm going to read you a
little bit about the legend of Al Capone
as it is today Al Capone's brief life
was florid and dramatic but his
afterlife is even more colorful and
outsized his reign as the king of crime
lasted for six short years and even
after he was stripped of power the
public still could not get enough of him
in the almost seven decades since he
died the frenzy of publicity he inspired
during his lifetime has increased
exponentially and shows no sign of
slowing down
he died in 1947 and in 2016 the daily
Google Alert still records anywhere from
half a dozen to two dozen new hits every
single day new books and films appear
about him almost every year and these
include novels biopics documentaries
even mockumentaries there are memoirs
that purport to tell the real truth
along with biographies for specific
audiences that include young adults and
very very young children one
eight-year-old told me well he killed
bad guys and that was okay because it
led him feed poor people the television
series Boardwalk Empire has made him
surprisingly not an antihero but a
genuine hero and younger viewers can't
get enough of him his name appears on
all sorts of lists including one from
the Smithsonian magazine that named him
one of the 100 most influential
Americans of all time in the entire
history of our country websites are
devoted to him and the mob museum in Las
Vegas gets
best crowds when exhibits feature him
Madame Tussauds Wax Museum in San
Francisco captured him after his disease
took over in the life-size statue of Al
Capone sitting in his Alcatraz cell
playing the mandolin and gangster
ologist as those who are fascinated by
criminals have been dubbed and
professors who proclaimed themselves
Capone scholars debate every aspect of
his life and if it can be called as such
his work Law School's study his court
case Bar Association's reenacted and
academic institutions from the most
August to the most local offer courses
Harvard Business School examines the
Capone outfit as a case study the
Kankakee Community College in Illinois
holds a course entitled simply Al Capone
and when it was first given it was so
popular that it was oversubscribed and
two more sessions had to be scheduled
restaurants claimed he ate their
cocktails and sandwiches are named for
him hotels claimed that he slept there
and there's even the laughable
contention that he often sneaked off
anonymously to play golf on Scottish
courses one reporter said it best if Al
Capone frequented even a tenth of the
places he said to have the notorious
mobster hardly would have had time to
build his Chicago crime Empire let alone
run the thing from musical groups to
young adult novels just his name in the
title can demand can't command far more
interest than most of them married cats
and dogs on internet postings especially
the countless pit bulls who bear his
name are sure to be quickly adopted his
name alone can secure a good table as a
young woman in San Francisco who bears
the hoenn surname finds every time she
tries to reserve a table in a posh
restaurant his face is on postage stamps
in Tajikistan where they evil I even
have one of may hiding her face behind a
fur coat and in Kyrgyzstan where His
image is centrally placed among the
notorious gangsters mugshots Al Capone
is at the center in Romania websites and
meetup groups proliferate and writers
and journalists there seek contact with
Americans who write about Al Capone's
life in crime in Bulgaria the Bulgarian
mafia claims they studied the outfit to
learn how to conduct their business in
England in the 1960s the Kray brothers
notorious for murder and extortion
modeled themselves after quote that
upper-class criminal Al Capone and in
Iceland the entire town of our burg is
allegedly obsessed with its week-long Al
Capone festival where all the residents
are devoted to the scourge of Chicago
when the Mexican drug lord el chapo
escaped from prison the comparison to Al
Capone was immediate and el chapo was
quickly dubbed the new public enemy
number one reporters don't stretch their
intellects when writing stories about
tax dodging hedge fund managers they
just make the immediate comparison to Al
Capone and the public gets the message
amazing mused a criminal defense lawyer
in Chicago how often his name is used to
spice up a story and without any
reference to who he is was or might have
been al capone's name is the one to
grasp when making comparisons with
everything from the current presidential
election to the finale of the immensely
popular television series Downton Abbey
it's so easy for everyone to compare
Donald Trump to Al Capone but Hillary
Clinton gets her comparison
as well Donald Trump is Al Capone on
steroids and Hillary Clinton is Al
Capone in a pantsuit and Donald Trump's
tax situation and Hillary Clinton's
emails get plenty of comparison and as
for Downton Abbey
the New York Times summing up the six
seasons of the PBS serial wrote that
that hapless servant couple Bates and
Anna who were each charged with separate
murders quote have spent more combined
time in jails and Al Capone people from
Chicago who travel abroad have a tale or
two to tell of what happens to them when
they say they're from Chicago the local
residents quickly form their hands into
a tommy gun and make the ack ack sound
and as one young man wrote on reddit on
the internet short time ago I get sick
and tired of tourists coming here in Al
Capone t-shirts but one of the more
thoughtful replies said the fascination
continues because idolizing Al Capone
just gets easier as time goes by and we
get more and more disconnected from what
he actually did and it's precisely this
disconnect that has contributed to the
unending question of what was there
about this man to turn him into an
international cultural icon and why the
mere mention of his name sets up a chain
of immediate associations writers have
long pondered the question of why this
particular man became the uber celebrity
among so many other colorful gangsters
and mobsters and why the legends that
have grown up around both sides of his
life the violent and the benevolent have
become so shrouded in myth how did he of
all the other outsize criminal
characters of his era become an
internationally recognized cultural
reference while so many others go
unrecognized today so now I'm going to
talk a little bit and I'm going to start
by telling you that he was born in
Brooklyn January 17 1899 and he was a
fourth son and the second one born in
the United States to Italian immigrant
parents Gabriella and Theresa Capone he
grew up in a family that kept to the
ways of the old country and that was
deeply steeped in every Italian custom
and tradition but all his life he was
quick to correct anyone and to become
angry every time he was called Italian
I'm an American I was born in Brooklyn
he would say and I am proud of it his
first home was a crowded tenement on the
street that led to the main gate of the
Brooklyn Navy Yard and he grew up
watching the boys who were in a local
gang called the boys of Navy Street he
watched while they'd hassle and assault
the sailors who poured out of the main
gate and as soon as he was old enough
which was probably when he was around 8
years old he joined this gang he was big
for his age
and he was a fast runner so no sailor
ever caught him and by the time he was
12 he had graduated from being the gangs
mascot to being one of its most
dependable and fearless fighters he
stayed in school through the 6th grade
which he had to repeat but not because
he was a bad student because actually he
was a very good student but because he
played hooky so often he was seldom in
the classroom
his parents believed in education and
they wanted all their sons to stay in
school as long as possible but every one
of them quitted first opportunity and
they found work such as it was in
penny-ante criminal activity al liked
school and he might have stayed longer
if he had not gotten into a brawl with
his teacher he knocked her down or maybe
he even knocked her out
and then we simply walked out of school
and he never went back and after that he
followed his two older brothers Ralph
and Frank into the criminal world and
this was after the oldest brother
Vincenzo simply walked out of the house
one day and disappeared not to be heard
from again for the next forty some years
and when Dinge Enzo came back he was
known as two-gun heart a gun-toting
horse riding cowboy in full regalia who
had been the lawman in Nebraska
dedicated to Smashing Stills and
enforcing the laws of prohibition all of
which his brothers had been actively
flaunting he can't make that up I was
leaving school was a particularly odd
who had worked hard to learn English and
he hoped that his sons would lead better
lives than his own he set himself up
Gabriel Capone as a barber while his
wife took in boarders and did peace work
sewing to help keep the family afloat
Gabriela thought he was encouraging Al
to become a legitimate businessman when
he bought him a shoeshine box and set
him up on Brooklyn's Columbia Street
under the famous clock instead al became
just the opposite from the ages of 14 to
18 he was a Brooklyn Punk who very early
showed signs of the street smarts that
he later used to run the Chicago Outfit
now his father did want Al to learn the
lessons of capitalism and in a very real
sense he did when the other boys saw
with a good location al had chosen they
set up their own boxes near his well al
didn't want to get his hands dirty so he
sold his box and then he rounded up some
other boys to intimidate the other
enterprising shoe shiners into paying
him protection money if they wanted to
keep on doing business they had to pay
Al Capone or else
so what are we going to call this are we
going to call it talent and such talent
did not go unnoticed by the various
Brooklyn crime bosses who were always on
the lookout for young and enterprising
hoodlums to join their rink so that by
the time Al was 18 he was working for
Johnny Torrio the crime boss responsible
for bringing him to Chicago and by the
time he was 19 Al Capone was also a
father several weeks before he became a
married man it was a most unlikely
marriage for this was early in the 20th
century when immigrant ethnic groups
lived in their own enclaves intended to
stick to their own kind and marry
Josephine Coughlin who was always called
May was Irish she was 2 years older than
L and very much above him on the social
rung of the immigrant groups who were
pouring into this country Mae's family
was lace-curtain Irish while Ellis was
the poorest of the poor the Cochran's
lived in their own house while the
Capone's lived in four small rooms on
the upper floor of a tenement walk-up
that was jam-packed with others just
like them
her father went to work in an office
every day in a white shirt and tie while
his father cut hair in the family
kitchen until he could save enough to
set up his own shop her mother went
directly from her parents house to her
own house and she never worked as so
many Irish girls did as a household
servant his mother clung to the ways of
the old country and was so frightened of
the world outside her building that she
never left it except for food shopping
and she called that going down to
America the marriage of Allen Mae was
highly unusual for several other reasons
in those days Irish girls who married
Italian men were said to have made mixed
marriages and the Italian partner
is commonly referred to as the colored
even more unusual the marriage did not
take place until several weeks after the
birth of their only child
Albert Francis Capone who was always
called sunny a mixed marriage such as
this brought almost as much shame to an
Irish family as did a pregnancy before
marriage but may stayed throughout the
pregnancy openly and proudly in her
family home al stayed in his and had to
visit the woman he desperately wanted to
marry but only when her mother wasn't
there as general generally believed by
the Capone descendants that mrs. Cochran
was responsible for the delay because
Mays pregnancy was a difficult one and
her mother thought she would miscarry
and therefore there would be no need for
a mixed wedding but sunny was born
prematurely after a troubled pregnancy
so May held firm and several weeks after
she gave birth she and L were married
before I talk about in his life in crime
I want to take a moment to talk about
the circumstances in which Italian
immigrants lived in the early years of
the 20th century I'm not using it to
defend the reasons that Al Capone turned
to a career in crime but I want to use
it to explain the world in which he grew
up it was a time when the New York
metropolitan area was swelled by around
800,000 people who came from Southern
and Eastern Europe and it was when
people like John Quinn the wealthy
Manhattan lawyer who bankrolled writers
like TS Eliot and James Joyce and Ezra
Pound despised every one of these
newcomers and this is what Quinn said
using one of the many slurs for Italians
and I quote there are seven or eight
hundred thousand degos a couple hundred
thousand slovak s-- 50 or 60,000 crow
apps and seven or eight hundred thousand
sweating
sing Germans they are all nothing but
walking appetites but new york city
government officials had a different
perspective and I quote again we can't
get along without the Italians we need
someone to do our dirty work and the
Irish won't do it anymore
only Jacob Riis who wrote about Italian
immigrants in his classic book how the
other half lives
saw the italian-american situation for
what it was and this is what he said
Italians have the instinct of
cleanliness but it is drowned out by the
nastiness of the tenements gangs of
every sort were rampant and it was
almost as if there was no other
possibility for an upwardly striving boy
to better himself than through a life of
crime now several things came together
just after Sonny Capone was born and
just after al married Mae and their
descendants and many of the scholars who
study his life and work believe that
this is why he turned away from
legitimate work to a life of crime just
after he was married his father died of
a heart attack at a very young age 59
years old and even though al was the
fourth son he was the dependable one so
he became the patriarch and the head of
his family the older brother had
disappeared the next two could not be
counted on to support their mother their
sister and their three younger brothers
and it felt L to provide for those five
people as well as his own wife and son
his family thinks he might have been the
legitimate businessman he always
proclaimed himself to be if he had not
suddenly become the sole support for
seven people and writers who study Al
Capone when he started his life in crime
they make remarks such as if he had been
born 30 or 40 years later he could have
been Lee Iacocca and the fact that the
Harvard Business School makes a case
sort of supports that possibility so I'm
not going to go into details now about
how he got to Chicago except I'm going
to say that he claimed one simple reason
for going there and I quote Al Capone
here I needed to make a living and I
thought I needed more once he got there
his rise was spectacular as one writer
put it and I quote here Capone would go
from a $15 a week mop boy an occasional
[ __ ] beater to one of the most powerful
and wealthy men in the world and he did
all this in the mere six years he was 25
when he took over and 31 when it all
ended and during those six years his
personal fortune was estimated at over
40 million dollars and by the time he
went to jail he was broke in the book I
wrote that his assent and mobbed him was
sensational and his downfall meteoric
and yet here we are almost 80 years
later and everything about that brief
time continues to command worldwide
attention interest and speculation and
one of the reasons I think is because
early on he learned how to co-opt the
media I credit Al Capone with the
invention of spin while other gangsters
stayed out of the limelight he courted
it he put reporters on his payroll and
with one editor in particular he offered
the first crack at scoops in exchange
for positive positive stories being
written about him he even tried to hire
one of the earliest and most famous
publicist to polish his public image
this was a man Ivy Lee who was known to
all as poison ivy Lee he was the man who
changed the public image of clients such
as john d rockefeller in charles
lindbergh and he very quickly declined
Al Capone's very
pitov offer i'll even tried to hire a
writer to ghostwrite
his autobiography painting him of course
as the saint and savior of everybody in
chicago but this terrified fellow was
let off the hook once the government set
his sights set its sights on Al Capone
and now had other things to worry about
again I hesitate to make comparisons to
the political climate of the current
election year but I can't resist doing
it and reporters vied to describe the
clothing he wore the bilious yellow or
pea green suits or the diamond pinkie
ring that was anything from 4 to 11
carats depending on who was writing
about it or the wads of silver dollars
that he allegedly threw from his
specially constructed fleet of
bulletproof cars and when he set up a
soup kitchen is a genuine act of
kindness in the depression reporters
were quick to say yes your kindness but
he extorted all the food he served from
small businesses and even after he went
to prison when there was nothing to
report or write about they invented
stories one headline read Al Capone lost
11 pounds another one was Al Capone read
a biography of Napoleon and the biggest
scoop of all in 1935 two Russian Soviet
writers were touring the United States
and in their book they wrote that al was
sitting in his Alcatraz cell secretly
writing anti Soviet articles that the
Hearst Newspapers were publishing so I
found out lots of surprising things
about Al Capone during the four years I
spent researching and writing the book
but where the most surprising was how
briefly he was on top of the criminal
world he was in a courtroom five five
and a half years after he ascended to
power defending himself but not from the
several hundred murder
he was thought to have ordered and the
several dozen or so he was alleged to
have been directly involved in he was in
the courtroom for tax evasion
particularly his income tax and by 1931
he was in the Atlanta Federal
Penitentiary
the most punitive prison in the country
until Alcatraz was set up in 1934
because the government wanted to send a
lesson to the criminal world that this
was going to be a prison whose name
would send shivers down the spines of
the most hardened criminals and who
better to imprison them public enemy
number one Al Capone
never mind that his brain was already so
riddled by syphilis that he had the
mentality of somewhere between seven and
twelve years of age his end was a sad
one as he was released early on because
the syphilis which he had contracted as
a very young man in which he gave to his
wife and son had so riddled that
mentality he didn't die in prison he
died in his own bed in his Miami house
surrounded by the family that loved him
and the wife who claimed she knew every
terrible thing he had ever done but she
still loved him anyway
he was only 48 years old and as I said
here we are almost eighty years later
with his name so widely known that the
Smithsonian put him on its list of the
100 most influential Americans of all
time what was there then about Al Capone
that captured so many different kinds of
imagination and I'm going to end by
reading just a few paragraphs again from
the book
a writer named Catherine fortune Giroud
in 1931 wrote an article about Al Capone
and she called him gorgeously and
typically American and I think she was
correct to say that about him because
his rise to fame so parallel the most
unusual moment in American history one
that could well fit that same
description and of course I refer to
Tobit prohibition it was curious early
form of political correctness that was
imposed upon the entire country when a
small number of fanatics convinced the
national government that laws mandating
universal behavior could be enforced it
was a weirdly schizophrenic time when
even the former president and later
Chief Justice of the Supreme Court
William Howard Taft observed with regret
that the strongest tendency of human
nature was the desire to lay down rules
of conduct for other people I don't
think would change very much have we
since then
unlike others who had wealth and social
station and used them sir tisha Slee to
defy the unpopular law that they were
often charged with enforcing Al Capone
ignored it and he told the truth about
why he did so he openly admitted that he
sold illegal alcohol to the best people
and he said he did it as a public
service to supply a demand that was
pretty popular for most Americans and in
the 1920s it made him an American hero
because he did publicly what most of
them had to do in hiding
Al Capone defied the law and he got away
with it it's an accepted truism that
cultural norms underwent seismic changes
at the end of World War one women got
the vote they shortened their skirts and
they went to work
jaded and disillusioned men refused to
join the traditional workforce and they
took off for foreign climes to create
the Great American Novel or to
revolutionize the art world and they're
opting out of what was known as the
traditional American Way gave rise to
the glamorous myths that have since
surrounded European expatriates the rich
who always got richer suddenly found
they had lots of company as the economy
soared and the middle class has found
themselves with lots of disposable
income the time was right for thumbing
one's nose at what constituted
acceptable social conduct and with a
flamboyant bootlegger leading the way
many others were as eager to break all
the smaller prohibitions and
constrictions on their private lives as
they were to disobey the large one that
was forced upon them by the eighteenth
Amendment
Al Capone led them on and the public
loved him even though he was largely
responsible for washing the streets of
Chicago in blood for most Americans who
did not experience such sites directly
newspaper photographs and movies that
portrayed sprawled and bloody dead
gangsters and bullet ridden cars were
only entertainment and far removed from
real life
evil was appealing it was even enticing
as long as it didn't touch them directly
evil had become entertainment
disconnecting the public even more from
the violence of the gang wars and Al
Capone's part in them James O'Donnell
Bennett was one of the first journalists
who tried to explain the phenomenon that
Al Capone had become and he described
how and I quote here with no conscious
effort he emanated menace while saying
please
he was the criminal version of a foppish
dandy in his luridly colored but
exquisitely tailored suits with the
handkerchief neatly folded in his breast
pocket ready to be whipped out to cover
the disfiguring facial scars whenever he
needed to smile for the cameras
everyone knew to beware of that smile
for is to turn sinister in a moment he
was in short the perfect human paradox
and the counterpoint to the political
paradox that was prohibition
he was so wildly charming so blatantly
outsized in everything that he did and
so fully in the public eye but it was
hard to believe it such a good fellow
and one so highly entertaining he of the
pithy quotation in the catchy phrase he
couldn't be all that bad
and as for prohibition it might have
been the law of the land but nobody took
us seriously so why not have that drink
that was how Al Capone fulfilled the
public's imagination and that was how he
was regarded until the market crashed
and once that happened public opinion
reflected the change new world of the
Great Depression public opinion is
easily diverted and fickle at best and
it turned against him not entirely but
just enough for people to feel
self-righteous satisfaction to say in
one breath that he got what was coming
to him and in the next that he got that
come up and in the shaky trial on
trumped-up charges and yet even as they
passed righteous righteous judgment they
remained alert for every scrap of
information about Al Capone's life in
prison and his tales of his mental
decline seeped out they were ghoulishly
avid for news the more bizarre the
better the stories written about him
during his lifetime
are often flawed in both content and
interpretation so arriving at the
factual certainty of public events is
diff is difficult the consent ins can
sorry the consensus is that arriving at
anything approaching a definitive
interpretation of the man who is
alkapone remains elusive all that we
have our speculation and probability and
they only lead to endless possibility
Oscar Wilde said of himself God knows
when he was asked what's posterity going
to make of you his answer Oscar Wilde's
answer is something that Al Capone could
have said as well and I quote somehow or
other I'll be famous and if not famous
I'll being notorious Wilde envisioned
himself is leading and again I quote a
life of pleasure for a time and then
after that who knows perhaps that will
be the end of me too and for now the
only certainty is time passes and the
man who is Al Capone recedes into
history the legend shows no sign of
stopping thank you
so open when you read a book it's a
one-way conversation after recess I know
you're going to want to have the
opportunity that you're going down right
now
so don't miss it if you have a question
you line up on saving fourth stare back
and we'll have you come forward without
the question and happy to answer it so
people realize okay I'll repeat it I'll
repeat it I'll repeat the question
sociology 4e ology of shoeshine boys I'm
sure you answered this later on but how
did he get away with all those murders
oh the question the basic question is
how he got away with all those murders
well he delegated he learned that from
Johnny Torrio and believe me Johnny
Torrio deserves a biography his own of
his own but I'm not going to write it
that's for somebody else Johnny Torrio
was a great delegator L didn't get his
hands dirty with the shoeshine kit and
he didn't get his hands dirty with the
murders the st. Valentine's Day Massacre
which if you're like me one morning I
had 12 different books spread out in my
office as I was trying to arrive at
certainty and every every single one of
them had a different version of who did
what to whom so I gave up on trying to
settle that question once and for all
but the point is when the st.
Valentine's Day Massacre took place Al
Capone was throwing a party for Miami
City government officials in his Miami
House and that's one of the ways he got
away with it no murder was ever pinned
on him as everybody seems to know he
went to jail for tax evasion and even
that was very shaky because income tax
was so new and there were so many
differences in the laws at the time
another question yes about the
background of how you came to write the
book well that's a very interesting
story all of my books begin everything I
write begins with either an idea that I
have or a question that I want to find
an answer for in this one in a sense was
a whole lot of questions I wanted
answers for but it began when a young
man with a surname Capone wanted to know
his family history he had heard a
particular version of his family history
that one of his uncle's or perhaps even
his own grandfather could have been an
illegitimate son of Al Capone and he
through a friend of his contacted the
friend's sister who worked in publishing
in New York City and she found me one
day and she said what should I tell him
should I tell him to get a private
detective or should I tell him to get a
ghostwriter and I said well I don't know
because I don't really know what it is
that they want to find out so she said
she'd get back to me she'd let me know
and perhaps I could help her and help
him and I started reading books I went
to the library and picked up two or
three books about Al Capone and I
thought this is an incredibly
fascinating man and having been a former
journalist and investigative reporter I
thought wow wouldn't this be the scoop
of the century and so one thing led to
another and I started out to write the
book so I went to my agent and my
publisher and told them that I wanted to
write about Al Capone and I'll never
forget the shocked expression on their
faces you Al Capone
but I'm very happy to say that they both
decided that it might be a pretty decent
book so why didn't I go ahead and write
it
while think of question or two more just
let me remind you that there will be
books available in the lobby it's
professor Merrill signs clear hmm open
you to Mike look so that man can hear
you there's a microphone right here oh
[Music]
here we go why why do you think people
in Bulgaria or Tajikistan what what
particular aspect of kelp alkapone do
you think they admired is murdering or
as extortion
I just it really boggles the mind
doesn't it I wish I could give you an
answer I think there are probably many
many answers to such a question but
those countries III do hate to
generalize but they do have a reputation
for what shall we call it disreputable
behavior and perhaps that has something
to do with it there are a lot of gangs
there there's a lot of poverty in
Romania in particular I know Romania
because I wrote about Saul Steinberg I
don't know very much about Bulgaria and
other countries but the poverty the
ghetto like way certain ethnic groups
have to live there are so many parallels
to the immigrant experience in the early
years of the 20th century and so I think
perhaps that might have something to do
with it they look at this immigrant boy
in Brooklyn who became a success and
they they may think that's the way for
them to go I other than that I can't
answer it
I'm sure there have to be don't feel shy
and what you were to add yes please just
going along with the different cultures
and like being attracted to him there's
a lot of like myths
within like Mexico like Malverde who is
sort of this Robin Hood type and maybe
like they have like some sort of myth of
their own that sort of goes along with
the lines of like Al Capone I've noticed
that with a bunch of different countries
that they all seem to have like this
myth of like this Robin Hood type
character and maybe that's what they're
sort of like you know sort of like
grabbing on to as far as as far as like
idealizing him sure excellent
observation
oh here comes summer
I've had the joy and pleasure of reading
the book and it is phenomenal and one of
the things I understand that
distinguishes this book is because of
your talk and work with the family about
it you the man is more human than we've
ever known the side of him that the
family man from their point of view so
could you say some more about that now
sure as I said he had he and may had one
son always known as Sonny and perhaps
because Sonny was a sickly child Sonny
did not go to school until he was and I
think the seventh grade he was
home-schooled and Mae was very
protective of Sonny that might have had
something to do with why he did not
follow his father into a life of crime
but also I believe that Mae was
responsible and I think Al wanted Sonny
to grow up straight if we will Sonny
went to Notre Dame he started at Notre
Dame and the joy that L felt in his son
being a student at Notre Dame University
was beyond stratospheric so Sonny had
four daughters he married his high
school sweetheart
and the four of the four daughters one
of them died of cancer and the three
others are still alive and I had the
great pleasure of getting to know them
as well as so many other family members
and they were young they were children
very small children but they were old
enough to have strong memories of their
grandfather and their grandmother and
they told me the stories of being they
grew up in Miami and they told me the
stories of being at the Palm Island
house with their grandparents who adored
them and
Maye lived to the 86 L died when he was
48 she was 50 then so she lived a very
long life after his death and she would
often visit these grandchildren and she
would tell them her stories and as one
of them said to me it was mama maze they
call her mama Mae and they said it was
mama maze reality and of course it was a
reality with rose-colored glasses we
understood that we knew it but we loved
her so we let her tell us these stories
so that was how a lot of family
background came in but then something
very interesting when I first started
talking to the granddaughters and I had
met a couple of other family members in
the Chicago area who were the
descendants of one of his brothers and
then someone phoned me and said you know
I'm living in the Midwest and I know a
whole big Capone family here and maybe
you'd like to talk to them they have
another name there they were all deeply
closeted all the brothers except Ralph
changed their name from Capone and they
did this during Al's lifetime they
wanted to get away from under his shadow
and I joke about this but this is true
I'm responsible for so many Capone
family reunions I can't tell you because
I introduced the cousins on the west
coast to the Midwest cousins to the
Chicago area cousins to the eastern
cousins and they have all met each other
I've been able to see some of these
reunions the grading motion that takes
place when they see each other
so I had lots of stories from lots of
different family members and friends
there was a 96 year old woman still
alive who knew many people in Al
Capone's immediate personal world and my
job was to take all of these stories and
to factor them into
what should we call it the most
objective the most real the most
probable possible version of his life
and so that's what I tried to do and
it's really interesting to me the
reviews and comments are starting to
come out you know the Internet is a
great thing we all let loose and say
what we think on it and there are people
there was one man just the other day who
wrote yeah sure he was a good family man
but Hitler loved his dog too so you know
there's going to be that kind of
response to the book and it's probably
appropriate and it's probably necessary
because he was so he had so many
different facets of his personality
every time I talked to the family
members particularly the granddaughters
we would use words like enigma conundrum
riddle and we all read the book and I'm
happy to say they have very positive
things to say about it but we all agreed
that my book is the first step it's not
the final word I the view that no
biography is ever definitive every
generation needs its own we don't know
the questions the next generation is
going to want to get answers for we can
only take care of our own time and offer
possibilities for further research
further writing and thinking further
understanding and that's how I see this
book I see this book as the tool that
other writers are going to need to
explore different facets of Al Capone's
life and again I'll use the word this
work
micki end with a very short story from
our museum which by the way is open
every day from one to five and we have
300 we have the forensic evidence of
bullets from the st. Valentine's Day
Massacre we have lots of interesting
things and we give you a tour of all of
this place but we also have remarkable
oral histories and then so I'm going to
butcher the last name because I'm doing
this from memory but little New York
companion was it companion one of the
Capone's lieutenants granddaughter came
to the museum and told us a wonderful
story about Ralph Capone which is so sad
and it's like books like this are so
important she said that she would go and
visit her grandfather in the old
people's home where he was in the same
home as Ralph Capone who would sit in a
wheelchair with a large fedora and she
would notice him all the time and
instead of asking her grandfather who it
was she asked one of the nurses and she
said oh that's Ralph Capone he still
thinks he that he is somebody and it
looks like this that so remind us of the
importance of everybody's life and that
you know these old treasures of memory
need to be found and talked about and
written about and thank you so much and
again please join us in the front lobby
and meets a professor dude there thank
you thank you all
you're a great audience